说话人 1: 哈喽，兄弟们，我是Jackson，今天给大家带来一期非常有价值的聊天
说话人 1: 为什么
说话人 1: 你们可以看到在线上可以做到整个流程的一个东西，可以让你们学习到非常多阶段的一个知识
说话人 1: OK，我们来说一下这个女生的一个背景情况
说话人 1: 这个女生她是我的学员，在群里面，代聊的一个目标，他当时是搭讪认识的
说话人 1: 值得一提的是，他在前期跟这个女生的接触当中，在聊天里面
说话人 1: 大概聊了 20 多页，可能几百回合，女生还是没有出来，相当于是一个黄灯，对吧
说话人 1: 她在犹豫，她的联系感不足
说话人 1: 这个时候我接手了，在群里面，大家也可以看到我是现场直播帮他聊的，没有丝毫造假的一个成分
说话人 1: 很多导师他的聊天记录，他给学员聊的都可能是造假造出来的
说话人 1: 为什么
说话人 1: 因为首先他聊的不对劲，其次他只是一张截图，对吧
说话人 1: 我的聊天是在群里面经过很多兄弟校检
说话人 1: 经过很多兄弟验证的，所以说是 100% 真实的
说话人 1: 在我接手这个兄弟的聊天之后，差不多在 20 多个回合就把女生给聊出来了
说话人 1: 你们可以看到，在这个过程中用到了非常多的技术
说话人 1: OK，我们废话不多说，直接开始讲解
说话人 1: 你们可以看到，这个学员在5月 9 号的时候，发了一个聊天给女生，发了两段话，女生没有回了
说话人 1: 在5月 19 号的时候，在我的群里面，我让他开了一个场，因为当时深圳在下雨
说话人 1: 我让她随便开了一个场，今天好大的雨
说话人 1: 女生说，你是在龙华那边下雨吗
说话人 1: 我上午在龙华，下午回龙岗这边了
说话人 1: OK，女生也描述了她的一个状态，对吧
说话人 1: 这个不重要，我们看接下来我怎么回的
说话人 1: 这里我直接无视掉她的状态，我们直接切入主题
说话人 1: 为什么在这里要切入主题
说话人 1: 还是我们的一个原则，你要去上你的男女前提，让女生知道你不是当她的闺蜜，你是要去操她的
说话人 1: 这时候我说，哎呀，别管那些了，只是想说快放晴了，想出去
说话人 1: 走走，对吧
说话人 1: 这是在埋一个铺垫邀约
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说这不是刚下雨吗
说话人 1: 刚开始，很多兄弟觉得，OK，女生在拒绝他，在什么
说话人 1: No，其实不是，女生的脑子里是知道你在约她的，她在矜持，为了让自己看起来不是一个，对吧
说话人 1: 因为在下雨，全都怪天气，对吧
说话人 1: 她又不想拒绝你，因为怕失去你，因为怕失去，可能在这个时候是一个备胎，可能失去一个追求者，她是不愿意失去的，所以说在这个时候她会找一些借口
说话人 1: 我说你那边停了没
说话人 1: 我们直接把这个物流给确定好，停了我们就搞出来
说话人 1: 我说停了的话，它结束就代表我们可能要开始了
说话人 1: 非常暧昧，非常强烈的一个男女意图，但是又那么的有艺术性，没有那么的一些直白，就会让女生觉得，OK，这个男的有点会撩
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说咋了
说话人 1: 你开始操作了
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个很重要，这是一个关键的节点
说话人 1: 女生说咋了
说话人 1: 你要开始操作了，什么意思
说话人 1: 你确实撩到她了，但是有一个废物测试就来了，她会觉得你对每个女生，对很多女生都这样，因为太会了
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们不要顺着他这条线，让自己看起来非常的浪，不行，我们要拉回来，把舒适感拉回来一点
说话人 1: 这个时候就是我的操作开始了，我说是我的操作，但是我的灵魂
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是OK，我是在用技巧，但是我是对你这个人对你这个人感兴趣，我才去用技巧，而不是说只是为了技巧而技巧
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说
说话人 1: 你操作一下，再让我见识见识
说话人 1: OK，上一个废测是过了，但是紧接着下一个废测又来了
说话人 1: 这个废测是属于他的高位废测，他把自己当成一个奖品，你来表现，你来演戏，或者说你来做一些什么东西来取悦我这种感觉
说话人 1: OK，我们不要进这样的框架，这个时候我敏锐的识别到了
说话人 1: 我说艺术是不能出现多次的，你目前是什么意思
说话人 1: 它是有两个意思，第一句话就是艺术是不能出现多次的，我的表演
说话人 1: 也好，我的技术也好，我的一些很的操作也好，他不能去疯狂的乱操作，操作多了就会觉得很廉价，这是第一点
说话人 1: 第二点就是你目前是什么意思
说话人 1: 就是我说它是一个艺术品，对于艺术品，我是需要好好的去做质量，而不是去做数量，是告诉他这样的一个逻辑
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这句话杀伤力非常的大，直接给妹子干趴了
说话人 1: 然后女生说好的，花的还算高级
说话人 1: 她是认可了我的话，但是还是在她做她的奖品框架，为什么
说话人 1: 因为学员在前面聊了 20 多页
说话人 1: 聊了 20 多张聊天都还没聊好，这会给女生塑造好一种奖品框架，所以到这里她还是没有完全的把她的高位给放下来
说话人 1: 这个时候我要拉回来一点我的能量，我说还好有点肉麻，对吧
说话人 1: 把我的能量拉回来了，我说啊这个东西有点肉麻，我不想再说了
说话人 1: 我还给她打压了一下，我说你喜欢肉麻，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个也非常的重要，这个是冷读，妹子喜欢这样的话，我是能看得出来，而且她也比较有窗口，这被我看出来了，所以说我说出这样的一个东西，让她自己明确的知道她是对我们有窗口的，知道吗
说话人 1: 我们能看出来女生
说话人 1: 对我们有窗口，这是我们的点，我们还要做到一个点，就是让女生彻底知道她是对我们有窗口，这样她才会破掉她的防御，懂吗
说话人 1: 这个很重要，兄弟们，这个是女性心理板块
说话人 1: 女生她接受了这样的一个副格，她说我喜欢麻，当然是食物的那种
说话人 1: 她跟你玩起来了，很多兄弟认为这是拒绝，No，她跟你玩起来了，她没有严肃的拒绝你，那就是接受，知道吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我说，那请你喝花胶奶茶，OK，这是做了一个铺垫的一个预设
说话人 1: 铺垫邀约的一个预设
说话人 1: 铺垫邀约在聊天上要持续的去做，这样才能让我们约她的时候没有那么突兀
说话人 1: 你能在每一次铺垫邀约看到女生的一次真实的邀约窗口，所以说这是非常保险，非常稳妥的一个做法，铺垫邀约
说话人 1: 然后女生说，她说我喝咖啡
说话人 1: 这个时候你就知道她是愿意答应你出来了，但是这个时候我们还是要把需求感压一下
说话人 1: 这个时候我说，喝咖啡不会睡不着吗
说话人 1: 就是来测一下她这个窗口到底是不是很真实，然后再把我们的需求感往回拉一下
说话人 1: 女生说睡不着跟咖啡无关
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们就无视她这句话，我说你随意，我主要是见你这件事情，无论是喝咖啡也好，喝奶茶也好，我都无所谓，主要是你人在这里
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 突出我们要建的一个主题，也是加强一下男女的一个框架
说话人 1: 女生说好好好，我懂，对吧
说话人 1: 就已经确定了百分之八九十了
说话人 1: 这个时候我们立刻要乘胜追击，我说忘了跟你定时间了，哪天
说话人 1: 要去马上把这个东西给变现，立刻做好一个契约性，这样才能把这个窗口给它升级，给它变现
说话人 1: 不然的话，你聊的这些东西都没有意义了
说话人 1: 这个事也就是我们的阶段收尾的一个意义
说话人 1: 女生说，她说这不是下雨了吗
说话人 1: 今天你约了谁
说话人 1: 女生的意思是她说有点下雨，可能有一点不想出来，这是第一点，我们要去解决掉这个问题
说话人 1: OK，下雨其实没影响，我们要去消除掉这个她自己认为的阻碍
说话人 1: 还有一点就是她说你今天约了谁，这还是一个废策，兄弟们，这还是一个废策
说话人 1: 我们先把这个物流先去解决了，她的地理位置，我们再去解决后面的一个废策
说话人 1: 我说你在哪
说话人 1: 她说啥
说话人 1: 我说今天可以见啊
说话人 1: 女生说你怎么没约别的妹妹
说话人 1: 她可能认为他是一条鱼，这个时候我们就要去解决这个问题了，因为她连续的问了两次，她还没把这个东西给解决掉，对吧
说话人 1: 我说你不也没约别的哥哥
说话人 1: 女生说，她说你是主动的呀，我都是被动
说话人 1: 我说我主动99，你1
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是我可以很主动，但是你必须要配合我，我们才能一起去完成这个事情
说话人 1: 女生说，她说怕不是跟别的小姐姐也这样，你们可以看出女生非常的没有安全感，因为可能我展示出的价值，展示出的属性有点短期，吸引力比较强，我们就要拉回来
说话人 1: 这个时候兄弟们，我回了一个很经典的一个东西，我说我敢爱敢恨，不像你
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是不给女生去解释，对吧
说话人 1: 我有很多女生接触，我不去解释，我也不去直面她这个废测，我用一个防守反击的一个方式，我说我对感情就是这样，我敢爱敢恨，我不像又怂又找各种借口又各种装逼，直接破掉她的防御
说话人 1: 很多时候废测，你不要去一贯的防御，知道吗
说话人 1: 你不要去一贯的防御，一贯的去在她的框架里面去解释，我们很多时候要
说话人 1: 要做一个反击，你才能把敌人给打倒，不然的话你会一直处于被动，我们要拿到主动权，兄弟们
说话人 1: 这个女生瞬间倍感住了，她说年纪大了，体谅一下，对吧
说话人 1: 她在疯狂的解释了，OK，我们要的效果已经达到了
说话人 1: 兄弟们要知道在聊天里面，你要持续这样不断的去battle，把女生给打趴，直到她彻底的臣服，你才能获得你想要的结果，兄弟们
说话人 1: 这个时候我在做一个鼓励，我说不试一次怎么知道还会不会冲动
说话人 1: 我在鼓励她去做投资
说话人 1: 这个女生她为了不让自己输，她发了一个表情流汗，她说咋说
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们可能会被这样的表情干住，知道吗
说话人 1: 我知道你们，兄弟们，你会被这样的表情给干住，为什么
说话人 1: 因为在我很久很久以前
说话人 1: 我也被这样的表情给干住，在我准备真情流露的时候，女生发了一个很不解风情的表情，一个什么的话，对吧
说话人 1: 但是不要怕，这只是她不敢去投资，不敢往深的投资的一种体现
说话人 1: 她想让男人先撕开自己的面具，她才敢脱下她自己的衣服，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我们就一定要坚持住，我说见，今天就我把我的目的完全说出来，我们要见了才能把这些东西聊清楚
说话人 1: 还有一个点，我说你吃了吗
说话人 1: 这是在做什么
说话人 1: 这是在做一个假定成交
说话人 1: 如果说兄弟们，这个技巧非常重要，假定成交
说话人 1: 如果说我说你吃了吗
说话人 1: 她说
说话人 1: 你干嘛
说话人 1: 我不出来，什么什么，他会直接拒绝你
说话人 1: 但是只要他说他吃与没吃，那都代表我们是可以去做邀约的，懂不懂
说话人 1: 这是一个非常好用的一个技巧
说话人 1: 女生说，她说还没有吃，OK，我们马上抓到机会，立刻开始进行一个变现
说话人 1: 我说跟你聊挨了一会饿了，要不走
说话人 1: 跟你聊挨了一会饿了，这是在合理化，我们要很紧急的去约她，你要立刻马上我们来见面，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是做一个场景的一个铺垫
说话人 1: 我们还为了我们下一句合理化
说话人 1: 要不走，对吧
说话人 1: 加强一下他的一个语气，是这样的一个作用
说话人 1: 女生说，她说今天外面很难排，可能是到周末，对吧
说话人 1: 可能是下雨，OK，她怕有点难排队
说话人 1: 学员他是在群里跟我说，他说他有海底捞的免排特权，因为他可能是VIP，OK，他想说把他的海底捞 VIP 身份发给这个女生，他说可以展示价值吗
说话人 1: 我说没必要，这个不是什么身份，对吧
说话人 1: 这也不是一个很强大的特权，你只需要给到女生一种我能搞定一切的感觉
说话人 1: 她就没有顾虑了
说话人 1: 所以说在这里我给出了一个话术，这个话术它不是一个很神奇的作用，但是它很有艺术性，同时也代表了我能扛住所有责任的一个意思，让女生彻底的放松
说话人 1: 然后我说我安排，听党指挥，能打胜仗
说话人 1: 然后女生秒回啊，回的很快，她说去哪里
说话人 1: 我还想说要不要在家里吃点，女生还在犹豫
说话人 1: 可以看到这个女生她是非常的优柔寡断的，非常的谨慎的，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这种女生可能看起来短期，但实际上她是比较长期的女生
说话人 1: 他是非常谨慎的，他没有那么有安全感，这个时候我们需要识别到
说话人 1: 我让学员给他发了一个位置，女生又出现了一些问题，因为地理位置有点远，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员发了一个你在哪，就是知道他的位置
说话人 1: OK，你们需要去调度，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是在调度你和女生的一个行程安排，你需要知道他的地点、你的地点、你们约的地方、你们的时间，各方面都需要你去调度，不要让女生去调度，你要让女生最大的动能
说话人 1: 最大的几率出来，同时能让你最大程度的让自己很轻松，让自己没那么费劲，知道吗
说话人 1: 这就是我们相当于是一个谈判的一个效果，但是没有那么严重
说话人 1: 学员是不想去那么远嘛，对吧
说话人 1: 这里我帮他支了一些招，看试探女生究竟是什么情况，不愿意从那么远过来
说话人 1: 于是我先说，我给你叫个车吧，排队你不担心
说话人 1: 我还给出了第二个选项，还是你晕车，不想太远，知道吗
说话人 1: 我们要把所有的情况分析出来，让女生做选择，我们不要让女生去做一个责任的一个付出
说话人 1: 你要让她选 A 或者选 B 就行了
说话人 1: 在女生想选的时候让她选，在女生不想选的时候不要给她选项，这是灵活的，不是说你听了某些 PUA 课程，你说啊不要给女生选择，直接去做决定
说话人 1: No，那是很的，那是没有成熟的体系
说话人 1: 女生说啥日子啊
说话人 1: 你 12 点能见到我吗
说话人 1: 我怀疑，因为女生很怕堵
说话人 1: OK，但是让她有点夸张，对吧
说话人 1: 只是为了掩饰她
说话人 1: 不想出来，只是为了让你去，要不下次吧，让你说出这样的话
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们要来一波激将法，做一个失格，把这个东西立刻给它加强去变现
说话人 1: 我说怎么跟个女人一样，磨磨唧唧的，对吧
说话人 1: 实际上我就是想说她别逼逼，别墨迹，只是用上了一个技术性的表达手法，怎么跟个女人一样
说话人 1: 我在用这句话的时候，这是我自己发明的一个话术，我在用这句话的时候，一般女人 99% 都会回，就是女人啊
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 情绪就出现了，这个时候我们更好去做决定，更好去改变她的一些决定
说话人 1: 她说我是女人啊，你要跟我做兄弟吗
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 情绪已经出来了，哪怕她说这样的话，你们感觉不出情绪，但我知道情绪已经出来了，这个时候我就能去影响她的一些决定
说话人 1: 我无视她这样的一些回答，我直接说你化妆要多久
说话人 1: 女生说你先随便吃点好吗
说话人 1: 就是可能会耽误比较久，她说晚点再过来，这时间碰不上
说话人 1: 我说好，到了你饿了再吃点，就是我们还会见，我还是要给她把这样的预期做出来
说话人 1: 很多时候我们要去流转女生的决定，必须要自己坚持
说话人 1: 我说出门时跟我说吧
说话人 1: 隔了一阵子，女生说你要不要过来
说话人 1: 我还没吃饭呢
说话人 1: 我说不早说
说话人 1: 现在我来吧
说话人 1: 女生还在那里，因为她其实，她不是不想见，她是觉得很麻烦
说话人 1: 这里我们要加强一下自己的投资进度，让女生知道这个东西是没有可选项的
说话人 1: 我说一半了，到了说
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说我还在朋友家呢，她在做饭，对吧
说话人 1: 她还是在做一个假性的拒绝，她说啊，我在朋友那里，我还没吃饭，什么要不要你晚点过来
说话人 1: 这样的一个意思
说话人 1: OK，我说多久
说话人 1: 今天能见吗
说话人 1: 我不跟她逼逼，我直接让她做一个快速的一个，她想要的，心里面的一个决定
说话人 1: 因为她怕得罪我的话，她就必须想见，她就必须要见，这是人下意识的反应
说话人 1: 所以说这个东西它是很好用的
说话人 1: 女生说人还在做饭，你到哪里了，对吧
说话人 1: OK，这个时候就已经确定了
说话人 1:  10 分钟到你发的定位处
说话人 1: 女生说饭都还在做，笑死，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候就已经完全的她接受你见面的一个场景了
说话人 1: 我在这里上了一个框架，我说我不喜欢迟到，我先吃东西了，好了叫我
说话人 1: 这里我们才知道女生最大的一个顾虑，这个时候她才出现，她说你介意吗
说话人 1: 我素颜，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是这段话的一个主要的信息
说话人 1: 她害怕你看到她不好看，对吧
说话人 1: 因为女生的素颜都是很丑的，特别是这个女生，她还强调了我素颜，就代表她素颜可能真的比较丑
说话人 1: 可能没有眉毛，看起来很没精神
说话人 1: 兄弟们，不是你们想的那种丑，不是，是跟她化妆之后完全是两个人，这个很正常，不代表她是，这只是她气血不足，或者说她的眉毛比较稀少，看起来就不好看
说话人 1: 我在这里用了一个消除评判的话术，我说第一次见真实一点好
说话人 1: 然后女生说什么
说话人 1: 怕吓到你，对吧
说话人 1: 她还是有顾虑，那么这个时候我们要给出一个很好的一个阅历来破解她这个东西，这个可能一般兄弟没法去理解，但我在这里告诉你们，我说我不是没见过女人素颜哦，你越说我越好奇
说话人 1: OK，就是让她知道我其实见过很多女人素颜，我知道OK，女人素颜是什么样子，会比较丑，我还能接受，对吧
说话人 1: 我没有什么评判，让女生知道这个信息，她就会瞬间打开
说话人 1: 女生你看，兄弟们一下子就打开了，她说哈哈哈，好好好，你在哪里随便吃了点，对吧
说话人 1: 到时候就直接邀约了，到那个点他们就直接见面了
说话人 1: 非常快速的一个邀约，在差不多一两个小时之内就搞定了
说话人 1: 你们要想一想，兄弟们，这是一个没有窗口，甚至于黄灯，甚至于偏红灯的一个女生，给她聊成这样，立刻邀约出来做一个变现
说话人 1: 同时兄弟们，你们可以看到我的操作非常的凶险，这个女生很多
说话人 1: 很谨慎，很奇葩的一些问题都需要去解决
说话人 1: 这个东西不是一两天都能学会的，它是要长年累月的一个社交直觉，以自己的一个阅历积累才能搞定这样的一个东西，才能把这个女生给干住，不然很多时候你们只能吃定率的
说话人 1: 差不多就是这样，后面学员去约了一个足浴，在足浴里面尝试一些收尾，一些操作，也是我给他的一些建议，因为很多兄弟可能没在足浴，可能没跟女生约过足浴，可能没去做过这样的一个情景，但是在我的经验里面，足浴是非常放松的
说话人 1: 也是比较中性的一个环境，他可以去往男女方面延伸，他也可以去做下次的一个邀约，做下次的一个约会的一个铺垫，可以让你更安全的去做长期的一些建设
说话人 1: OK，后面就是女生的一个跟他制定约会地点的一个情况，还有后续的一些操作
说话人 1: OK，这是他们去约足浴，OK，这是见面的
说话人 1: 一个聊天，OK，他们当时还在玩什么游戏，对吧
说话人 1: 还是很有联系感的
说话人 1: OK，这是他一约之后回去的一个界面，做了一些联系感
说话人 1: 这是我们的第一部分，怎么去破解女生的废测
说话人 1: 怎么去破解女生的高位框架
说话人 1: 把女生给约出来，过程也是非常的曲折，用了很多的一些技巧，这是我们邀约部分
说话人 1: 在下一个部分，我们会详细讲解跟女生怎么在线上去把关系拉深
说话人 1: 直到一个男女朋友的一个位置，非常的干货，兄弟们，特别是想要学习怎么在线上把女生给干住，全程干住，不敢出来跟女生见面，不敢去搭讪，不敢去什么，可以帮你在家里轻轻松松把妹子给干住，那就要好好学习接下来的这一部分聊天
说话人 1: OK，我是Jackson，下期再见，兄弟们
说话人 2: 我的侧翼被迂回了，我的中央撤退了，但我在进攻
说话人 2: 一战后来的结局要让我很幸福，战争进行到后期就是无聊的，而且是看不见头的消耗战，双方都在拼，谁也不可能轻易的前进，谁也不可能轻易的被打败
说话人 2: 德国是从 1916 年2月开始实行
说话人 2: 之前德国人没有做任何准备，所以他老早就陷入到
说话人 2: 到了战争快结束的时候， 18 年初的时候，德国国内每个人分到的食物大概只有一战结束，面粉类食物只有一半，肉类只有六分之一
说话人 2: 燃料缺、衣服缺、咖啡缺、水缺、酒缺、鸡蛋缺，非常非常的，非常非常的
说话人 2: 因此呢，为了应对这种工艺，大量的工业化、化学化生产，会带有，也带有一定的污染
说话人 2: 还有我们说的盒子，也就是我们小时候拿一包，带着橡皮，香肠
说话人 2: 另外呢，还有
说话人 2: 所以啊，德国的这种，会把经济，实际上在一战结束之后，不但没有缓解，还加重，因为凡尔赛体系，讨账的是，德国的经济赔偿，这个更要命，整个 20 年，多膨胀，大家领回来了一波一波的钱
说话人 2: 德国也有黑店啊，也是卖人肉的，卖包子的
说话人 2: 在哪
说话人 2: 就在柏林
说话人 2: 当时因为有原料供应太，所以有人就
说话人 2: 当时有大量的
说话人 2: 很多很多的
说话人 2: 但我也不是做
说话人 2: 这个肉铺专门
说话人 2: 德国的航空发动机都可以使用合成燃油
说话人 2: 为什么这么做呢
说话人 2: 因为德国的煤炭
说话人 2: 所以如果煤转油的话，可以把
说话人 2: 当时德国高速的时候，没有石油也没有飞机
说话人 2: 女孩子喜欢穿的靴子
说话人 2: 我也是原因，我一室内烧油的机动车开的越来越少，大家都变成电，而且后来由于男人打压，所以有一段时间这个开电车的都变成了女孩子，而且还是那种年少貌美，标新少女，所以一段时间内，很多的男人突然就改变了习惯，原来的东西
说话人 2: 但是这树上你得挂东西呀，这树你见过光秃秃的圣诞树
说话人 2: 对吧
说话人 2: 所以挂什么东西
说话人 2: 没东西，家里人真玩没了，这是个大问题，所以大家只能在上面装饰一些假的
说话人 2: 橱窗里的，商店橱窗里的，街道两旁的
说话人 2: 加定的， 13 年，意大利
说话人 2: 所以呢，橘子就没了
说话人 2: 到了 44 年底，苏联收复，法国也收复
说话人 2: 鸡蛋就是在这个时候变成
说话人 2: 就在这个时候
说话人 2: 好
说话人 2: 到了 45 年就不用说了
说话人 2: 俄国人是这样，你像打仗是天天被轰炸，天天
说话人 2: 老百姓能不能好好
说话人 2: 他当然会有怨气，德国人再有纪律，他也不是一个没有感情，没有血性，当然会有很多
说话人 2: 只要一个城市被，只要一个城市遭受到大轰炸，立刻
说话人 2: 当然我们说的纪律，如果把所有的话
说话人 2: 道路上，这样的远去，相对，更重要的是，只要一走到，就大着锅就来了，然后大大冒着热气，你想想这对于那个饥肠辘辘的德国老百姓，尤其是孩子，时不时的给你
说话人 2: 但是如果没有
说话人 2: 刚才说了德国由于在战场上，所以在 40 年到 42 年， 43 年初这段时间，德国国内的情况，老百姓虽然受到战事，虽然没有那么便利，但是起码在 43 年初的时候
说话人 2: 但是到了 44 年
说话人 2: 再往后到了 44 年底
说话人 2: 但是一直到四点东西
说话人 2: 这个为什么
说话人 2: 为什么打仗的时候
说话人 2: 这个阿登纳呀，他是一个有民主思想，所以这个在纳粹德国时期，当然是个反派
说话人 2:  1944 年7月的时候，当时有一次反对的事件，其实是阿登纳
说话人 2: 第二呢，到 9 月份的时候，他又被抓到了监狱
说话人 2: 当时这个监狱
说话人 2: 这样，阿登纳在告别了新兄弟之后，回到家时候已经是深夜，家里人一开门，没人想到阿登纳居然这么早
说话人 2: 当时的东德，阿登纳大家都觉得，再回来再走
说话人 2: 这段时间一直到战争结束
说话人 2: 到了有一个，双方在交火的时候，到了有一个新的
说话人 2: 然后呢，在后花园里还，猫着身子，不要引起别人的注意
说话人 2: 他居然还站起来，这一下他一站起来
说话人 2: 对于九角龙的此刻的阿登纳一家人
说话人 2: 所以啊，阿福大家和两个女孩就要利用这个时间
说话人 2: 沿着花园的院墙挡眼，花园旁边的那些花，也是都挡眼，猫着腰，有时候要爬着，就这样，在比较隐蔽
说话人 2: 当时，科隆市面临的情况，所有的东西都被破坏，下水道、街道全部被断，电车轨道、自来水管道、电线电缆全部被接，所有的桥梁，莱茵河上的桥梁没有一座，整个城市下来，只有300
说话人 2: 而就在这个时候，因为战争结束，大量的难民
说话人 2: 这个情况在德国的很多地区都有，就是德国的难民潮在战争结束的一前一后出现两次，盟军即将打过来的时候，战争即将在城市打响，大量的人为了躲避战争
说话人 2: 但是等到战争过去以后，大家都急急忙忙的赶回来，因为生化战力很强，压力很大，没什么，但是大家都害怕
说话人 2: 别的在很多城市都发生，战争一结束，许多许多的本来是急急忙忙离开的人，大量的难民
说话人 2: 没住的地方还好，因为毕竟
说话人 2: 就算没有房子住，你搭个帐篷啊，或者临时搞个地铺，两人一人，你还能
说话人 2: 最要命的是没有吃的
说话人 2: 马拉多纳把当时所有能找到的，能留下的，还能够继续开路的，能够通过的车，然后让这些人去，到乡下找一些农民
说话人 2: 当然更重要的办法就是
说话人 2: 其实提出这种要求的太，德国哪个领导不缺
说话人 2: 到处都在向美国
说话人 2: 但是美国人还是比较给阿登纳面子，阿登纳后来才知道自己是美国人开列的一个德国人，可以合作的，值得信赖的这样的一个白名单的名单
说话人 2: 尤其是在年轻人， 20 到 30 岁这个，这个男女比例增加，而且他没有保证
说话人 2: 这个 100 个， 171 个， 100 个男人里面有大量的剩男，就算不到残，就算没有到中年
说话人 2: 战争带来的精神
说话人 2: 好多人在自己的日记转写的过程当中，德国妇女一个人苦苦的支撑着这个家，有的时候几个妇女抱团在一起，互相勉励，互相帮忙支撑着这个家
说话人 2: 他们的老公，他们的男友
说话人 2: 他们就是非常期盼自己的丈夫，都保持着这样希望，可是有一天，当前线自己的男友
说话人 2: 其实上演的更多的是
说话人 2: 再有呢，男生对女孩也是这样，等离开的时候，一个个都貌美如花，多么喜爱的水灵灵的，等到回来以后，直接
说话人 2: 自己心目当中，在前线的时候，在进行一个战斗的时候，充满了希望，写信的时候都充满了希望，等到真的回来的时候，见到自己的
说话人 2: 好吧，今天的时间比较晚了，就先聊到这